right before my dad died the last day he
lost his ability to speak and all he had
was eye contact and I'm telling you man
what went through our eyes and that last
day was totally profound if I have the
privilege of living long enough to see
my hair turn gray and if I have the
experience the joy of having
grandchildren that I can hold in my
son's spotted hands and if on my final
day as my body shutting down I lose my
ability to speak with only my eye
contact left
I would hope Ken Odessa Bluma my brother
and sister and best friends and
grandchildren are all gathered around me
leaning into me close enough to hear
what my eyes are saying and here's what
they try to convey more presence more
appreciating more compassion more
laughing more dancing more making more
kneading dough more mistakes more I'm
sorry more I forgive you more eye
contact more hugs more daydreaming more
silence more eating together at the
table more reading more journaling more
taking a beat more thinking in slow
motion more rituals more nature more
getting lost more empathy more joy more
authentic connecting more looking up
more love thank you
[Music]
you